flic sainte olives en direct de toulouse
blagnac alors le premier essai en vol de
cet avion aura lieu à la fin du mois de
mars ou au début du mois d'avril au plus
tard le premier vol commercial sur
l'a380 se fera sous les couleurs de la
singapore airlines en avril 2006 dans un
an et demi et le premier vol d'air
france est programmée pour avril 2007
c'est à dire dans deux ans et demi voici
le portrait de cet avion superlatifs
signé nicolas chateauneuf et isabelle
d'oignons l'avion de tous les records
lorsqu'il entrera en service l'airbus
a380 sera le plus gros avion de ligne du
monde
un colosse de 73 mètres de long et 2 80
m de large qui pèsera jusqu'à 550 tonnes
au décollage pour faire voler un tel
engin les ingénieurs d'airbus se sont
surpassés l'a380 est un concentré de
technologie premier atout le recours
massif aux matériaux composites et aux
fibres de carbone qui ont permis de
diminuer le poids de l'avion sans
négliger la sécurité
autre avancée le cockpit comme dans son
simulateur il sera entièrement
électronique le papier a disparu
l'ordinateur de bord gère la plupart des
paramètres on retrouve également les
commandes de vol électriques un système
doublonner qui a fait le succès d'airbus
de cette manière le pilotage est
optimale et les possibles erreur
corrigée pour construire l'a380 chaque
pièce a fait l'objet d'intenses
recherches les quatre moteurs par
exemple
à eux seuls ils représentent un tiers de
la valeur de l'avion les constructeurs
anglais et américains annoncent deux
fois moins de bruit et une économie de
15% de carburant par rapport au
concurrent le boeing 747
enfin l'a380 est un énorme succès
logistique fabriqué par quatre pays
en angleterre les allées les moteurs en
allemagne et en france
le fuselage en espagne l'empennage
le tout est acheminé par air et par mer
à toulouse où l'avion est assemblé
finalement l'a380 pourrait emporter
jusqu'à 840 passagers de paris à
melbourne en australie sans escale